an entrepreneur friend of mine asked me
how do you think I could add five
million dollars in profit in my business
and do no extra work and so we sat down
for 90 minutes thinking about all the
different things in our business finally
figured out a way she can make five
million more dollars extra profit per
year for no added effort and what that
experience taught me was how important
asking the right questions were it
wasn't how do I make more money how do I
make more Revenue it was the constraint
of I want to do nowhere and make five
million dollars the questions provide
the guidelines for the answer and so if
you're not getting the answers you want
you're probably asking the wrong
questions